good morning believe nation today's
message is practice success before you
are successful over to you Dan Pena and
to practice success before you're
successful one of the stories and I know
Peter remembers that before I had any
money I used to go to the rolls-royce
dealers and sit in the cars and smell
the leather touch the leather okay and
these days this is 40 years ago I went
the million dollar houses and my wife
and I would walk through the house and
they'd say one of your parents getting
here kids no we are the buyers okay and
to get used to it and that's the reason
the castle is so effective and the
reason I stopped giving outside seminars
is that the success rate is almost five
times greater going to the castle having
a butler wait on you dressing thinking
more of yourself because self-esteem is
the key to high performance if we feel
good about ourselves and we hang around
with people the average of the five
people that we are mostly around is whom
we turn out to be this is a great
message and one that I can resonate not
in that I would go to different houses
and do tours of places that I couldn't
afford but more than that I think all
entrepreneurs have limiting beliefs we
are positive our environment the people
you surround stuff with the information
you consume and your environment holds
you where you are and so if you want to
change where you're going you have to
change your environment to market as
well and the bigger your dream is the
further away where you want to go is
from where you are now the harder it's
gonna be because the less support you
have around you and so I remember one
day when I was meeting with my
mastermind group and I was talking about
wanted to change the world if that looks
such a big goal it felt like it was
beyond me and I felt like I can talk a
good game but I felt
it didn't actually fully believe that I
could and so one of the things that
really helped me was this YouTube
channel the aunts presto series the top
10 series surrounded myself with people
even if I've never met them just their
information their thoughts or ideas
people who have done so much more than
me people who are changing the world
people who are doing big projects and
are impacting millions of people and by
being surrounded by them on a regular
basis I absorbed not just their wisdom
and ideas but absorb the motivation from
them and gives me the self-confidence to
feel like I can go and do that too
so my question that they for you guys
today is how do you practice success
before you are successful leave it in
the comments below I'm gonna join in the
discussion thank you so much for
watching have an amazing day continue to
believe and I'll see you again tomorrow
morning for another shot of an espresso